also ich bin im turnverein
er wollte was gedacht und es willkommen
beim neuen video
ich habe heute den hashtags ages prinzen
dabei wieder mit aktuellen die heute und
sie drehen heute homosexuelle vs
heterosexuelle beim date
hallöchen und ich bin der alexander
freue mich erstmal dass das so
hingehauen hat ja noch ein bisschen
nervös aber ich glaube das gehört dazu
beim ersten hallo ich bin meinem
schlechten ich ja echt sexy du bist echt
fair abzielt schon auf den ersten blick
wirklich mal ganz ehrlich sagen
einmaligkeit faultier zu sein solange
überall wo geschrieben bei architekt wir
miteinander verbracht haben was möglich
war endlich jemand grund jetzt endlich
kinder wissen was sind so deine hobbys
also ich bin im turnverein g ab und zu
spielen mit meinen engsten freunden mit
meinem freundeskreis und den kontakt zu
mädchen habe ich bis jetzt eher
vermieden und weiß ich hatte einfach ich
suche ja keinen richtigen freund
eigentlich eigentlich schon aber
irgendwie auch eine affäre mit dem ich
hatte richtig spaß haben kann nicht
exakt haben kann
und ja verstehen weil das ding es hat
einfach dass männer immer so böse zu mir
sind mich immer fahren lassen nach zwei
wochen eigentlich nur ein loch wollen
und deswegen will ich ab heute
beziehungsweise seit neuesten irgendwie
mag ich hoffe das ist jetzt nicht
schlimm für dich oder so aber du weißt
er unter männern ist es normal was hast
du so für eine schulische ausbildung was
machst du da so du hast doch bestimmten
abitur oder hasst durchschnitt von unter
das heißt du bist schon dumme nützlich
ist so was will ich eigentlich nichts zu
tun haben natürlich ich war auf dem
latium habe dabei ein abschluss vor zwei
jahren gemacht mit 13 wollte eigentlich
10 haben damit ich psychologie studieren
kann hat nicht ganz hingehauen
aber für so was interessierst du dich ja
nicht so jetzt den eindruck ich wärme
einer psychiatrie aber aber aber
natürlich ich kann sich ja voll
verstehen mit deiner meinung und sind ja
voll und ganz zu so ist sogar auch
nichts anderes außer ich gebe weißt du
ich hab gesagt das ist einer fähre durch
aber nicht du aber das ist doch genau
das gleiche
genau das was ich brauche meine
liebesaffäre aber jetzt was für einen
gefunden
ich bin jetzt bankkaufmann seit zwei
jahren habe auch schon die filiale so
gut wie übernommen weil ich so gut im
geschäft bin aber ich glaube nicht dass
du jemals so viel erreichen will wie ich
jetzt schon in zwei jahren
ich meine was wir mit einer
waldorfschule 134 war das geht ja gar
nicht
nein ich brauche auch einen mann der mir
ab und zu machen das schöne tor tat
zukauf paar neue prada schuhe meine
haarfarbe rabatt bei waldshut affäre
soll auch aus liebe bestehen und nicht
nur zu drücken
bild macht zwar spaß aber du verstehst
mich nicht kann
du bist aber nicht so eine die mit jedem
ins bett springen oder so wenn man mal
so macht oder
weil ein bisschen so aus den tussi schon
dein stil gefällt mir auch nicht das ist
viel viel zu weiß ich nicht aber ganz
ehrlich mit der affäre ein sorry falls
jemand anders aber ähnlich doch auch
einen mann der eine kreditkarte hat mir
volle wachstumsschub free youtube vids
leute das war's erst mal mit diesem
video aber noch nicht wegschalten
gebt euch ohne scheiß das video von dem
prinzen hier das ist in der sie
beschreibt ihr lasst euch tot ohne
scheiß jetzt echt das mietrecht
anschauen dann der russe da kann man es
auch unten in der radio beschreibung und
das mädchen also mein erstes date flirt
partnerin auch instagram in der video
beschreibungen und hier geht es weiter
mit meinen letzten video und ich würde
sagen dass nächste woche 33